ahora queremos encontrar la raíz cúbica
de 3.430 y bueno si eres como yo no te
salta directamente a la mente en este
segundo que en número si lo
multiplicamos por sí mismo tres veces o
sea así tenemos ese número por ese
número por ese número nos da tres mil
cuatrocientos treinta entonces lo que
voy a hacer es factorizar este número
escribirlo en su factor y zación en
primos y ver si alguno de esos factores
primos aparece por lo menos tres veces
entonces saber 3.430 pues termina en 0
así es que es divisible entre 10 o sea
que es divisible entre 2 y entre 5 pero
pues vamos a empezar con el 2 porque es
el primo más chico entonces 3.430 entre
eso es 1715
dos por mil 715 es tres mil 430 y haber
este número es divisible entre cinco
entonces vamos a poner un factor primo
por aquí y por acá nos queda a ver vamos
a hacer la división por acá
17 15 entre 5 pues el 5 cabe tres veces
dentro del 17 3 por 5 nos da 15 y le
ponemos un símbolo de resta 17 menos 15
son 2 bajamos el 1 y el 5 que ave cuatro
veces dentro del 21 5 por 4 es 20 no se
nos olvide restar 21 - 20 es 1
bajamos el 5 y 5 por 3 es 15
entonces nos queda residuos cero así es
que 1715 es igual a 5 por 343 343 aunque
entonces ya nada más nos falta
factorizar 343 al verde amos será
divisible entre 2
porque no es para entonces no lo podemos
dividir entre 2 lo podremos dividir
entre 3 a ver 3 + 4 73 10 el 10 no es un
múltiplo de 3 entonces este número
tampoco es divisible entre 3 no es
divisible entre 4 porque no es divisible
entre 2 tampoco es divisible entre 5
porque no terminan en 0 ni en 5 y
definitivamente no es divisible entre 6
porque ni es invisible entre 2 ni es
divisible entre 3 entonces pues tenemos
que ver si es divisible entre 7 y bueno
generalmente cuando no es divisible ni
entre 2 mientras 3 ni entre 5 lo que
tenemos que chequear es si es divisible
entre algunos de los otros
por ejemplo 7 11 13 entonces pues veamos
empecemos por ver si 343 es divisible
entre 7 si no es divisible entre 7
entonces tenemos que ver si es divisible
entre 11 y luego entre 13 y luego buscar
más números primos pero a ver empecemos
con el 7 a ver 7 por 5 nos da 35
entonces el 7 cabe cuatro veces en el 34
7 por 4 es 28 lo restamos y nos sobran 6
bajamos el 3
7 x 9 es 63
y tenemos de residuos cero así es que
sietes y divide a 343 entonces 343 se
factorizar como 7 por 49 y el 49 pues
muy probablemente ya te saltó a la vista
porque el 49 es 7 por 7 un cuadrado
perfecto aunque y entonces encontramos
la factorización en primos de 3.430 es 2
por 5 por 7 por 7 por 7 porque entonces
podemos escribir esta raíz cúbica como
la raíz cúbica de y en lugar de poner
3.430 vamos a poner la factorización en
primos o sea 2 por 5 por y aquí pues
podríamos poner 7 por 7 por 7 pero pues
también podemos poner 7
ok porque aquí con esta expresión de 7
al cubo lo que estamos representando es
justo 7 por 7 por 7 entonces esta raíz
cúbica es igual a esta raíz cúbica lo
único que hicimos fue escribir al número
en su factor y zación en primos y ahora
podemos usar todas las propiedades de
los exponentes porque recuerda que una
raíz cúbica es igual a el número 2 por 5
por 7 al cubo
elevado a la potencia un tercio aunque
entonces esto es igual a la raíz cúbica
de 2 por 5 aunque sabes que déjame lo
escribo de otra forma de una vez 2 por 5
es un 10
por la raíz cúbica
de 7 al cubo pero pues raíz cúbica de 7
al cubo es un 7 aunque hay esto también
lo podemos ver como 7 al cubo elevado a
la un tercio que es igual a 7 elevado a
la 3 por un tercio y 3 por un tercio es
1 así es que esto es igual a 7 a la 1
que es igual a 7 aunque pero bueno el
chiste es que todo esto es igual a la
raíz cúbica de 10 por 7 y esta raíz
cúbica de 10 ya no se puede simplificar
más porque 10 es simplemente 2 por 5 y
ahí sí ya no hay factores primos que se
repitan por lo menos 3 veces entonces
pues si puedes calcular la raíz cúbica
de 10 pero va a tener decimales y ya no
es un trabajo que debería de hacerse a
mano puedes sacar tu calculadora y ahí
sí te va a dar un resultado con
decimales
pero esta expresión es la más simple a
la que puede llegar a mano aunque la
raíz cúbica de 3.430 es igual a 7 por la
raíz cúbica de 10